mehr als 100 kletterer steigen in die
wand des falkenstein seien 81 meter
hoher felsen in der sächsischen schweiz
die meisten wählen die route die 1864 5
tonner aus dem kleinen ort bad schandau
für die erstbesteigung des freistehenden
felsens gewählt haben ein wunderbares
stück die bürger mit einer einzigartigen
oder mit einzigartigen geschichte mit
einer einzigartigkeit was ist klettern
ein verlag und so leben jetzt lese
einfach weg zu denken das jubiläum 150
jahre bernstein man einfach dabei sein
unbedingt dabei sein wollte auch
christian walther aus dresden
für mich ist das durchaus lebensinhalt
seit fast 30 jahren gehe ich long und
ich genieße es heute wie am ersten tag
das klettern im weichen sandstein der
sächsischen schweiz ist für bergsteiger
eine besondere herausforderung
für den kopf man muss sich überlegen wo
kann man sich sicher und muss sich
durchaus überlegen kann ich mir das
überhaupt zu tragen man muss mir denkt
man muss schon erstmal vorher denken ob
man überhaupt nicht ob das macht selbst
gesehen für ein ist der fels ist was
ganz besonderes es anders als in anderen
gebirgen er ist irgendwie weicher
sanfter er ist irgendwie manchmal auch
lebendig als lettern in der sächsischen
schweiz hat für mich ganz viel mit
meditation zu tun ganz viel mit sich
selbst ausloten seine eigenen grenzen
auch kennen zu lernen
bettina wobst kennt jeden felsbrocken am
falkenstein
sie hat einen film gedreht indem sie die
erst besteigung des berges aus dem jahr
1864 nach inszeniert hat
man begibt sich eine gewisse höhe aus
der man auch unter fallen kann man weiß
nicht wie kommt man wieder zurück also
für mich waren das fünf mutige männer
die toner benutzten eine leiter als
hilfsmittel bis zehn jahre später gelang
die besteigung des benachbarten felsens
mönch ganz ohne hilfsmittel die
geburtsstunde des sächsischen
freiklettern das später als free
climbing die ganze welt erobert anders
als beim klettern in den alpen
verzichtet man in der sächsischen
schweiz darauf haken und keile in die
wand zu treiben gesichert wird mit
methoden die den sandstein schonen das
verwende ich hörte sich um
wir benutzen in sachsen sehr viele
natürliche möglichkeiten zum anbringen
von sicherungen zum beispiel solche
phantom die bergsteiger folklore bei der
jubiläumsveranstaltung am falkenstein
betrachtet bernd arnold skeptisch mit
mehr als 900 erstbegehungen teils in den
höchsten schwierigkeitsgraden hat er die
gipfel der sächsischen schweiz
erschossen
er ist einer der besten kletterer der
welt und mit seiner philosophie vorbild
für die junge generation die zielsetzung
kommt von dir du bist der maßstab du
musst dich nie an anderen orientieren
können
du bist mit ihr beschäftigt bis das
schönste weil ich finde immer durch
vergleiche man sich sächsische
auswanderer brachten ihre art des frei
kletterns in den 1930 er jahren mit in
die usa ab 1970 wurde das free climbing
dann auch in europa populär
es war eine der grundlagen für den
kletter buben der letzten jahre immer
mehr großstädter erklimmen mittlerweile
die wände in kletterhallen sport zu
machen
die schönen trotzdem durch das bewegen
in der dritten dimension ungewisses
abenteuer hat selbst wenn die gefahr in
der halle nicht sehr hoher ist hat der
mensch als ur instinkte irgendwie auch
die angst vor dem runterfallen und die
zu überwinden
das muss man auch noch klarer halle und
ich denke dass es das was es klappt und
ausmacht klettern eine sportart die
heute millionen begeistert und deren
geschichte vor 150 jahren hier am
falkenstein begonnen hat